Film Courage: Well I think it was a cable-access show
somewhere in Austin or something...it was
a great interview maybe he was like I'm
not sure how long ago was but they had
asked you about it about you know the
first one and they said you know what
tell us and you're kind of you were very
modest about it and said you know you
didn't want to make too much of a big
deal about it you also said that.
Filmmaker Richard Linklater: Hollywood is amazingly open to people's
ideas as long as that entertainment
brings money to it yeah so how do you
approach them making your films do you
do it is it simply just you're making it
for yourself or do you also keep in mind
who your audience might be yeah I think
when you're working on a very low budget
the way we are on these we really are
making these for ourselves I mean we
definitely have an audience in mind I
mean it that's you know we're
constructing this thing to be consumed
by what we think is a pretty smart you
know certain audience we have high
regard for so but yeah we put most of it
out of our minds and just put our bar is
really high like we're our own biggest
critics we put so much pressure on
ourselves to maximize this thing we're
trying to do that we each films gotten
progressively more difficult and it
didn't have to be it could get easier
but we just push ourselves because we're
compelled to to try to make to dig in
deeper and make something that is more
interesting to us so I think a lot of
sequels could go the other way let's
just show up and have a good time and
sure you know by Cannonball Run 4 you
know it's a fun movie
but you have the feeling you're invited
to their party right but you know this
is kind of the opposite we're really you
know kind of compelled in some strange
way to to go into this again you know
you know Jesse and Celine are these
characters we've created or kind of you
know emerging and wanting to be heard
from again or something some strange way